si tu as faim c'est toi qui régale
l'oncle sam
monsieur le président ce tournant
décisif de la guerre est aussi le plus
dangereux pour tous ces trésors qui sont
le patrimoine de l'humanité
les nazis vol des oeuvres à voir ce riz
amsterdam/paris jeu doit constituer une
équipe pour sauver ce qui peut l'être et
retrouver ce qui a disparu
les monuments de semaine signée par
roosevelt vous êtes combien pour
l'instant si ce seigneur 1 victoire en
trois sets
il n'a pas passé l'âge si on vous a
choisi parce qu'on a besoin de vos
connaissances et de vos compétences
bienvenue à la guerre sergent dire en
fait nos classes en angleterre dont
classe et ben je crois que je vais
rester là nous avons pour mission de
retrouver et de protéger plus de 5
millions de pièces de collection et
d'oeuvres d'art volées
voici la maquette du projet de musée du
führer ce sera l'un des plus grands du
monde
il lui faut des heures pour le remplir
c'est pour ça qu'il n'a pas bombardé
parle et la bombarde landes
c'est ce que je dis oui on aurait aucun
matériel lieutenant aucun matériel et
aucun effectif
je dirais que ça s'est bien passé les
allemands sont en fuite mais il s'en
vend les mains pleines il va donc
falloir qu'on avance le plus près
possible du franc
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous y avez des
milliers de pièces il prenait des photos
qu'ils envoyaient les clairs il va
falloir qu'on entre en allemagne avant
la troisième armée pourquoi est-ce que
je vous aiderai à voler notre regard
on peut exterminer toute une génération
raser les maisons des gens ils les repas
tirons
et si vous détruisez leur mémoire leur
histoire c'est comme s'il n'avait jamais
existé
c'est ça que veulent claires et c'est
pour cette raison que nous nous battons
c'est un ordre signé par hitler il
stipule que s'il meurt ou si le reich
est là qu ils doivent tout détruire
attention n'approche pas je crois que tu
viens de poser le pied sur une mine
pourquoi t'as fait ça il se passe
apparemment le lieutenant a mis le pied
sur une mine
pourquoi t'as fait ça vous avez vraiment
passé trop de temps ensemble